wildfires are raging across the west
coast burning down
millions of acres of land and wiping out
entire communities
this has put a renewed spotlight on the
conversation surrounding climate change
and its impact
on our planet joining us to discuss this
and more is former presidential
candidate tom steyer
he's also a philanthropist and activist
tom thank you so much for joining us
today
madison it's great to be with you so
you're in san francisco uh this is
personal for you how has your experience
of the fire's been
well i think that people throughout
california
have been experiencing the fires through
the incredible amount of ash
and particulate matter in the air
so that in san francisco a week ago
there was so much of that in the air
that literally they had the street
lights on at noon
it felt like the sun never rose and they
have been cautioning us
for the last week to stay indoors that
it's dangerous it's hazardous
to go outside of course
three when three and a half million
acres of your state
burn that means that for
some californians this has been much
more than just
you know a scary uh atmosphere to be
living in
that means their houses are burning down
that means their communities are burning
down
and in the case of the first respondents
that means they're risking their lives
to go out and try to battle 8 000 fires
that have
burned in the state of california so far
this year this has been something that
has touched
every californian you know in some
significant way and it says
you know it really brings home the idea
that here
we are living the climate crisis as a
state
we're experiencing right now it's not
something in the future
it's right here present with all of us
so tom what would you say to folks who
aren't necessarily familiar with
how these wildfires are intrinsically
linked with
climate change i'd say that in this case
it's really obvious madison
because we've had record-breaking
breaking heat
in california at levels which are
historic but almost hard to comprehend
i think we've had the highest recorded
his uh
heat in history anywhere on the planet
in death valley this summer in
california
but you know that's death valley so
that's a place that sounds like it might
be pretty
ominous in san luis obispo
which is a seaside college town it got
it with the mediterranean climate
it got to 120 degrees last week
so what we're seeing here is extreme
heat
followed you know which sets this state
up and the
forest line is a tinderbox followed by
literally thousands of fires
that burn you know that rage and so
there's no way
not to connect the record-breaking heat
with the record-breaking fires that
follow shortly thereafter
and we've heard varying responses from
public officials on these fires uh i'm
specifically thinking about the clashes
between the president
and former vice president joe biden what
do you make of their reactions to the
fires so far
well i think mr trump has doubled down
on his lies about climate
and i think that that is you know he's
clearly playing
politics with the lives of americans and
the future
of all americans just as he did in the
coveted crisis where
it wasn't convenient for him politically
to tell the truth and to save american
lives
and so you know i think that's very
consistent
with the pr with mr trump's behavior in
trying to gut environmental regulations
and actually to exacerbate and intensify
our climate crisis
and conversely i've talked to vice
president binding
numbers of times about climate i talked
to him backstage at the debates
i've talked to him numbers of times
subsequently he really gets
it he understands this issue
if there's one thing you should know
about joe biden it's that he cares about
people when he talked this week about
the climate crisis
across america but specifically with
regard to these fires on the west coast
he was talking about people suffering he
was talking about
people's houses burning he was talking
in terms of the floods about people
getting flooded out
he gets this intellectually he
understands the science
but more than that he gets it at a gut
level
that we're going to have to have a huge
response
to this and the good news is because he
cares about people
that response is going to be a huge job
generator you know a huge creator of
middle class good bang union jobs
and it's going to be a chance for us to
clean up the air and water
across the country but particularly in
underserved black and brown
neighborhoods
and so it's something where we have
somebody who doesn't care about people
fundamentally and doesn't tell the truth
fundamentally
and now we have a chance to elect
somebody who gets the facts
accepts the facts deals with the facts
and fundamentally
at his core cares about the american
people and will do what he has to do to
protect us
and you know it couldn't be a bigger
difference
tom you mentioned the impact of climate
change on black and brown communities i
want to zero in with you
on uh talking about that a bit more how
does climate change impact people of
color and specifically how does that
intersect with
some of the coronavirus health
disparities that we've seen in these
communities as well
well let's just start let's start with
the
environmental justice aspects of climate
if you go across the united states of
america and i've been
traveling as an activist
for a decade what you see
is that the air pollution is
concentrated in neighborhoods the asthma
associated with it concentrated
neighborhoods and those
are overwhelmingly black and brown
neighborhoods and that if you go to the
places
where you get sick or die from drinking
water the flint michigans
the denmark south carolinas the west
fresnos in the valley in my home state
those are overwhelmingly black and brown
communities
this country has concentrated its toxins
and its pollutants in those
neighborhoods and in fixing our climate
problem
it is inherent that as we come up with
climate policy
we start with leadership from those
communities
we start with policies that address
those very real
environmental injustices and that's
precisely
what joe biden's climate plan does and
if you look at covin
black and brown people across this
country disproportionately
have gotten exposed to this virus
because they are disproportionately
essential workers so they have gone to
their jobs they've been exposed
and in addition they've
disproportionately
suffered from it because of pre-existing
conditions
based on other historic injustices when
we
look across this country in the natural
world and we look
at environmentalism the people
suffering from environmental ruination
from environmental problems are
disproportionately
african-american latino native
and so as we approach it it's absolutely
critical that people from those
communities
be in leadership positions that the
policies
start with them so that in fact if you
get that right
we'll get climate change and in fact you
know that is
i've been working on this for a long
time i've always known
that the media got this wrong the media
has always tried to portray
american environmentalists as
well-educated white people
but if you actually go travel the united
states
talk to people see who you know where
people's hearts are
actually and the poll numbers support
this medicine
latinos are incredible environmentalists
off the charts
african americans are disproportionately
environmentalists off the target
asian americans it's not what the media
would have you believe
this is a grassroots-driven
environmental justice
motivated movement it has to be that's
what's appropriate
you know that is in 2020 and
you know it's been true forever that is
how we should think about
environmentalism
it's a human-driven thing that we have
to be just about it
that it will create millions and
millions of good paying union jobs
and so as we solve a climate problem
we're dealing with
associated connected problems of
employment
and justice that everybody is feeling
and that are you know
broad-based in our society tom you
mentioned the
economic impact of uh working towards a
safer planet for all of us i'm wondering
if you were to
talk to a ceo and try to convince them
that
that being environmentally friendly
would help their bottom line what would
you say
i would say anyone who thinks
that we have to choose between the
natural world and a strong economy
doesn't know what they're talking about
we did a study gosh
at this point it's five to ten years ago
with ceos from across america with
republicans with independence to say
acting on climate you know addressing
climate
fundamentally will create more jobs
faster growth
better payment in addition to dealing
with our health problems and our
environmental problems
so anyone who's on the other side of
madison is either ignorant or lying
this is a huge positive for american
workers and american businesses and
anyone who's on the other side
is making up facts for their own sake
there's no question here that whether
this is good for the country
the issue here is to make sure which joe
biden really does
is that when we think about this we
don't just create these millions of jobs
but we make sure that they're
good-paying middle-class
union jobs and that we are thinking
about
every single worker in declining
industries
and making sure that we're respecting
their dignity
their right to provide for their
families that we take that
responsibility absolutely seriously and
that's one great thing about the vice
president is
everybody knows he cares about working
people and working families and he would
never
abandon them and you're
on biden's uh environmental or climate
advisory council rather
are there any upcoming changes to his
climate action plan that you can give us
a sneak peek into or anything
you can have with him on that you know
let me say this
there aren't but he has a fantastic
plan that he and his campaign and
other activists worked on for months and
it really
you know i think you look at two
trillion dollars being spent in the
first four years
100 clean electricity by 2035
net carbon neutral by 2050 economy-wide
joe biden is has a very progressive
aggressive plan and the other thing that
we have to remember madison
is this only 15
of the greenhouse gas emissions come
from the united states
this is a global problem you know yes we
have to
acknowledge the problem which our
existing president refuses to do
yes we have to deal with our own
situation
and have the kind of progressive plan
that joe biden has proposed
but more than that we have to have the
credibility
around the world to get the 85
of the greenhouse gases emitted by the
people outside the united states
and lead a coalition to solve a global
problem
and you know obviously this president
doesn't meet any of those hurdles and
joe biden has a
long history of international experience
relationships and really can get that
done
that's what actually has to happen for
us to succeed here
we have to come together as a world
because if the united states is perfect
and the rest of the world goes along its
merry way
we don't we don't solve anything
and tom you've been raising the alarm on
this issue for
a long time is this moment different in
your eyes
at all well we don't know yet madison
in all sincerity i will say this you
know i started the
largest youth voter mobilization effort
eight years ago
next gen america in american history i
know the people in your generation the
18 to 35 year olds
absolutely understand that your future
is
inextricably tied to climate action
if we don't have the kind of urgent
progressive
action that i'm talking about and that
vice president biden is proposing
that your future is changed
vastly for the worse and so from in in
terms of is this moment different
you guys already got it there's no doubt
in my mind
i do believe that watching
these fires across the west coast record
numbers of cyclones
in the gulf a hurricane hitting
louisiana alabama mississippi
you know the number this isn't climate
is not a west coast problem
it's an all 50 states problem and so
do i think people are getting this i
think they've been
getting it i think now people are
realizing
this isn't next generation's problem
this isn't tomorrow's problem
this is an urgent problem that we
absolutely
have to address right now
the only good news i can say is we have
the tech to do it we've got the know-how
americans are really doing a great job
on research
you know we have an ability to change
our political system
in less than seven weeks that is
probably the
single most critical thing we can do to
save the planet
so it's in our hands and i think
americans are
smart that's what i've learned in 10
years americans are smart
they're decent and compassionate we're
brave
we can do this we have to choose to do
it together
and i think this will be the biggest
accomplishment you know to
in in the way that i described creating
jobs along with a justice program
that we can ever do and you mentioned
your non-profit next
gen uh nextgen's own polling shows that
a lot of
young people are unsure about how to
vote particularly during covid
uh so i'm curious do you feel that young
people
uh can or the biden can count on young
people to really get out and vote
well let me say this i would never say
count on madison because this is an
issue you know i think every person
who's in the running for president like
joe biden
can't count on people has got to reach
out
and i believe he is you know in this
climate program he is really reaching
out to young people
and i believe from what i can see it
next gen
and what i can see in the primaries
leading up to really today
is that your generation the 18 to 35
year olds in this country
in my mind i am optimistic will vote at
historic levels
well more of them will vote than have
ever voted in history
that your generation absolutely the
biggest most diverse generation in
american history
has the ability to take control of this
situation has the ability to lead and i
believe that will happen on november 3rd
and i believe that you guys will sweep
in a transformative new government
across the board and that it really will
be
of course it's not all about climate but
that is an absolutely
critical part of it we saw that in the
massachusetts primary
for a climate champion ed markey turned
out more than twice as many people as
usually show up in a democratic primary
there
and so we're seeing real evidence
that young people are responding they're
responding to joe biden
and i really believe this is the it's a
do or die moment madison
and i believe that as americans we're
gonna do
tom you've used the word optimistic
several times which is fascinating to me
in this conversation about uh climate
change and i'm wondering
for folks who just feel like climate
change is such a big problem
they don't have any ability to to make
things better
what's your message to them what what
makes you hopeful right now
well we do have the tech that it's
unquestionable that
we're ahead of where anyone thought we
would be in terms of clean energy and
the ability to transform our economy
and we do have the ability to transform
our political system if we all show up
so the number one thing people can do
right now
is commit to vote and to get all of
their friends and relatives to vote
because i'm a huge believer in the
wisdom of the american people
and so the reason i started next gen
america was to say this
if the largest generation in american
history is voting at half the rate of
other american citizens
is that a reference a true
representative democracy no it isn't
we need young people to show up and
their voices to be heard
the power in that combined voice
is world-changing absolutely
world-changing
and so if we show up on november 3rd
as a people and demand that our
government do the right thing
then we're going to get that and i'm
very optimistic i believe in the
american people
i believe young people are going to show
up i believe we're going to see a
transformational
generational change and that we're going
to then have the ability
in terms of the moral right the
technological capability the political
you know crowds to get this done and you
know short of that
yeah the news from the natural world if
you're living in california if you're
living in
you know the southeast of the united
states if you're following the science
which i do
somewhat obsessively then you know we're
in crisis
but all that says is okay we need to
rise and meet the challenge
that's not the first time americans have
heard that we need to rise and meet the
challenge so let's just go do it
and you're also co-chairing governor
newsom's economic recovery task force in
california i'm wondering
what your plan looks like to help
californians recover
not only from losses from coronavirus
but also financial losses
related to these fires now well you know
the governor in my mind exactly
correctly has been saying for us to get
the most robust recovery
we first have to get the health
situation under control
and if you're following that the numbers
on the health situation
have continued to get better and better
what we've said from the very beginning
of our task force
is this yes we want to come back in
terms of jobs
employment and growth as strongly as
possible but we want to do it
in a just an equitable fashion so we
have a huge premium on equality
and we have a huge premium on doing it
in a sustainable
green clean energy fashion so when we
look about coming back
we know we're going to have to rebuild
this state
i think we have to realize that we can't
rebuild what we had
what we need to rebuild is something
that takes into account what you just
asked about earlier madison which is the
inequities of how people are suffering
in terms of the virus
the inequities that exist systemic
inequities that existed before
racial environmental and economic and we
have to rebuild something that's
sustainable we can't be building
a state or a country that is going to
you know have the guts in it that ensure
we continue on this same
unsustainable climate path we've got to
do it in a way that really
is you know works with
the biden plan in terms of
yes being sustainable and dealing with
the climate
yes creating those jobs and dealing with
the environmental injustice
that have existed really for as long as
we've been around
and when talking about environmental
injustice you mentioned the importance
of really speaking to people in these
communities and
hearing from them about how it impacts
them have you advised a former vice
president biden on any individuals who
might
uh provide good insight into the
handling of environmental injustice
you know i have over the last
decade plus met some of the
most impressive environmental justice
leaders across the country i mean and
some the ones i first met
were politically within my home state of
california
where the environmental movement and the
legislation in the last 10 years
has been led by legislators like eduardo
garcia
from some of the poorest uh districts in
california
you know so yes i've tried to make sure
that the people that i've met along the
way
you know the people who have been living
environmental
injustice their whole life and then
leading in their communities against it
so
yes i've tried to make sure that the
harold mitchells
who's a guy from south carolina whose
family
grew up next to a toxic plant parents
were sickened
he was sickened has been a leader in
that community now
for decades tried to make sure that
people in the biden campaign
got the opportunity to meet some of
these leaders so that they can get the
wisdom and let me say this
the vice president has always
this is just in his wheelhouse caring
about people getting poisoned
i mean if you know joe biden you know
that he immediately
viscerally responds to an injustice done
to the most vulnerable
and the other thing that's true about
this is
like i described just two people out of
a number and i
i hate leaving anyone out there just
happened to be two people who've done
amazing work but there are a lot of
other ones
including i say in new york city but
what you realize is they have real
wisdom on these topics that is deep
they also have no real wisdom about life
do they get climate yes they get the
science and climate there's no question
about it
but they can put it in a context that's
rich and deep and let me say one last
thing about this madison in terms of
connect
dividing campaign we haven't done it
recently but we used to go to
the most toxic most polluted zip code
in every state we were in just to see
what it was like
and let me say we almost always met in
the when we had those meetings
in church basements they were
uniformly communities of color
someone on our team would always have to
be excused from the meeting to go into
the bathroom and cry
so when you see this going on when you
see communities
where the life expectancy is 20 plus
years
lower than their neighboring communities
when you see people
and they point to their family and they
say dead dead dead dead dead
in their 50s you know when you see
people
really dealing with toxins pollutants
over an extended period of time it's
heartbreaking
it's absolutely you know i mean there's
nothing sadder
than seeing people poisoned and killed
systematically through a community and
so you know when i talk about
environmental injustice people use words
like pollution
and you know very kind of scientific
academic words it's poison it's human
being suffering
it's young kids lying in their bed in
pain
not able to go to school maybe not able
to live out their lives
that's what we're talking about tom i i
hate to make
things short here but i believe you have
an important phone call to get to so i'm
going to ask you one quick final
question
uh we've seen with some of these
stay-at-home orders some positive
impacts on the climate do you think that
any of the
changes we've implemented to combat
covet 19
should be continued in an effort to keep
our planet safe
well let me say this i mean i think the
big thing
that's happened in terms of the change
in behavior has been
the explosion of activity that's moved
from the physical world to the virtual
world
so for instance the number of doctors
appointments that are done virtually has
gone up
10 times the amount of people who work
from home
has exploded now are those things that
are going to solve
our problem long term i honestly don't
think so madison
i think for us to deal with this problem
in the way that we need to we need
federal action
along the lines of the biden plan does
the explosion of the virtual world
help it helps but we've got a much
deeper problem than that we've got an
infrastructure
across the country that needs to be
rebuilt we need to
weatherize and fix up commercial
buildings and houses across this country
we have to get around in clean
transportation
you know this is a really rebuilding
of america in a clean sustainable
fashion
that we have to accomplish together we
have to agree
that it's necessary we have to do it in
a way that it
makes our economy and our working people
stronger
and better off and we have to do it in a
just way it takes into account
historic systemic environmental and
racial injustice
but we can do that and we you know i
truly believe
that if we show up at the polls and
elect joe biden and flip the senate
and get in a new transformative
progressive government
that we are going to do it and we
absolutely have to do it i mean
the story to me of these fires and these
storms back east and what's going on at
the poles in terms of the melting
of the glaciers is we have to do it now
we have
you know people say how long do we have
to do this an answer is no time
we don't have a choice we don't have a
minute to waste
we can't lose this election everybody
has to show up
and we've got to accomplish this
together or it's not going to happen
tom star we can't thank you enough for
your time today for those of you
watching please continue to follow
bloomberg quick take wherever you get
your news on all social platforms and
again mr steyer thank you so much for
your time
madison it's such a pleasure to be with
you thank you so much